OK.
Here's lecture sixteen
and if you remember
I ended up the last lecture
with this formula for what
I called a projection matrix.
And maybe I could just
recap for a minute what
is that magic formula doing?
For example, it's
supposed to be --
it's supposed to
produce a projection,
if I multiply by a b,
so I take P times b,
I'm supposed to project that
vector b to the nearest point
in the column space.
OK.
Can I just --
one way to recap is to
take the two extreme cases.
Suppose a vector b is
in the column space?
Then what do I get when
I apply the projection P?
So I'm projecting
into the column space
but I'm starting with a vector
in this case that's already
in the column
space, so of course
when I project it I
get B again, right.
And I want to show you how
that comes out of this formula.
Let me do the other extreme.
Suppose that vector is
perpendicular to the column
space.
So imagine this column
space as a plane
and imagine b as sticking
straight up perpendicular
to it.
What's the nearest point in the
column space to b in that case?
So what's the projection
onto the plane,
the nearest point in the
plane, if the vector b that
I'm looking at is -- got no
component in the column space,
it's sticking completely
-- ninety degrees with it,
then Pb should be zero, right.
So those are the
two extreme cases.
The average vector has a
component P in the column space
and a component
perpendicular to it,
and what the projection
does is it kills this part
and it preserves this part.
OK.
Can we just see why that's true?
Just -- that formula
ought to work.
So let me start with this one.
What vectors are in the -- are
perpendicular to the column
space?
How do I see that
I really get zero?
I have to think, what does
it mean for a vector b
to be perpendicular
to the column space?
So if it's perpendicular
to all the columns,
then it's in some other space.
We've got our four spaces so
the reason I do this is it's
perfectly using what we
know about our four spaces.
What vectors are perpendicular
to the column space?
Those are the guys in the
null space of A transpose,
right?
That's the first
section of this chapter,
that's the key geometry
of these spaces.
If I'm perpendicular
to the column space,
I'm in the null
space of A transpose.
OK.
So if I'm in the null
space of A transpose,
and I multiply this big formula
times b, so now I'm getting Pb,
this is now the projection,
Pb, do you see that I get zero?
Of course I get zero.
Right at the end
there, A transpose b
will give me zero right away.
So that's why that zero's here.
Because if I'm perpendicular
to the column space, then
I'm in the null space of A
transpose and A transpose
b is OK, what about
the other possibility.
zilch.
How do I see that this formula
gives me the right answer
if b is in the column space?
So what's a typical vector
in the column space?
It's a combination
of the columns.
How do I write a
combination of the columns?
So tell me, how would
I write, you know,
your everyday vector
that's in the column space?
It would have the form
A times some x, right?
That's what's in the column
space, A times something.
That makes it a
combination of the columns.
So these b's were in the
null space of A transpose.
These guys in the column
space, those b's are Ax-s.
Right?
If b is in the column space
then it has the form Ax.
I'm going to stick that on the
quiz or the final for sure.
That you have to realize --
because we've said it like
a thousand times that the things
in the column space are vectors
A times x.
OK.
And do you see what happens
now if we use our formula?
There's an A transpose A.
Gets canceled by its inverse.
We're left with an A times x.
So the result was Ax.
Which was b.
Do you see that it works?
This is that whole business.
Cancel, cancel, leaving Ax.
And Ax was b.
So that turned out to
be b, in this case.
OK, so geometrically what we're
seeing is we're taking a vector
--
we've got the column space
and perpendicular to that
is the null space
of A transpose.
And our typical
vector b is out here.
There's zero, so there's
our typical vector b,
and what we're doing is we're
projecting it to P. And the --
and of course at the same time
we're finding the other part
of it which is e.
So the two pieces, the
projection piece and the error
piece, add up to the original b.
OK.
That's like what
our matrix does.
So this is P --
P is -- this P is Ab, is sorry
-- is Pb, it's the projection,
applied to b, and this one is --
OK, that's a projection too.
That's a projection
down onto that space.
What's a good formula for it?
Suppose I ask you for the
projection of the projection
matrix onto the --
this space, this
perpendicular space?
So if this projection
was P, what's
the projection that gives me e?
It's the -- what I want is to
get the rest of the vector,
so it'll be just I minus P times
b, that's a projection too.
That's the projection onto
the perpendicular space.
OK.
So if P's a projection, I
minus P is a projection.
If P is symmetric, I
minus P is symmetric.
If P squared equals P, then I
minus P squared equals I minus
P. It's just --
the algebra -- is only
doing what your --
picture is completely
telling you.
But the algebra leads
to this expression.
That expression for P given --
given a basis for
the subspace, given
the matrix A whose columns are
a basis for our column space.
OK, that's recap because you
-- you need to see that formula
more than once.
And now can I pick
up on using it?
So now -- and the --
it's like, let me do that again,
I'll go right through a problem
that I started at the end, which
is find a best straight line.
You remember that problem, I --
I picked a particular
set of points,
they weren't specially
brilliant, t equal one,
two, three, the heights were
one, two, and then two again.
So they were -- heights
were that point, that point,
which makes it look like I've
got a nice forty-five-degree
line -- but then the third
point didn't lie on the line.
And I wanted to find
the best straight line.
So I'm looking for the
-- this line, y=C+Dt.
And it's not going to go
through all three points,
because no line goes
through all three points.
So I'm going to pick
the best line, the --
the best being the one that
makes the overall error
as small as I can make it.
Now I have to tell you,
what is that overall error?
And -- because that determines
what's the winning line.
If we don't know --
I mean we have to decide
what we mean by the error --
and then we minimize and we find
the right -- the best C and D.
So if I went through this --
if I went through that point,
OK.
I would solve the
equation C+D=1.
Because at t equal to one --
I'd have C plus D, and
it would come out right.
If it went through this point,
I'd have C plus two D equal to
two.
Because at t equal to two, I
would like to get the answer
two.
At the third point, I have
C plus three D because t is
three, but the -- the
answer I'm shooting for is
two again.
So those are my three equations.
And they don't have a solution.
But they've got a best solution.
What do I mean by best solution?
So let me take time out to
remember what I'm talking
about for best solution.
So this is my equation Ax=b.
A is this matrix, one,
one, one, one, two, three.
x is my -- only have
two unknowns, C and D,
and b is my right-hand
side, one, two, three.
OK.
No solution.
Three eq- I have a
three by two matrix,
I do have two
independent columns --
so I do have a basis
for the column space,
those two columns
are independent,
they're a basis for
the column space,
but the column space
doesn't include that vector.
So best possible in this --
what would best possible mean?
The way that comes out to
linear equations is I --
I want to minimize
the sum of these --
I'm going to make an error here.
I'm going to make
an error there.
And I'm going to sum and
square and add up those errors.
So it's a sum of squares.
It's a least squares
solution I'm looking for.
So if I -- those errors are the
difference between Ax and b.
That's what I want
to make small.
And the way I'm measuring
this -- this is a vector,
right?
This is e1,e2 ,e3.
The Ax-b, this is the e.
The error vector.
And small means its length.
The length of that vector.
That's what I'm going
to try to minimize.
And it's convenient to square.
If I make something
small, I make --
this is a never negative
quantity, right?
The length of that vector.
The length will be zero
exactly when the --
when I have the
zero vector here.
That's exactly the case
when I can solve exactly,
b is in the column
space, all great.
But I'm not in that case now.
I'm going to have
an error vector, e.
What's this error
vector in my picture?
I guess what I'm trying
to say is there's --
there's two pictures
of what's going on.
There's two pictures
One picture is --
in this is the three
points and the line.
And in that picture, what
are the three errors?
The three errors are what
I miss by in this equation.
So it's this --
this little bit here.
That vertical distance
up to the line.
There's one -- sorry there's
one, and there's C plus D.
And it's that difference.
Here's two and here's C+2D.
So vertically it's
that distance --
that little error there is e1.
This little error here is e2.
This little error
coming up is e3.
e3.
And what's my overall error?
Is e1 square plus e2
squared plus e3 squared.
That's what I'm
trying to make small.
I -- some statisticians -- this
is a big part of statistics,
fitting straight lines is
a big part of science --
and specifically statistics,
where the right word to use
would be regression.
I'm doing regression here.
Linear regression.
And I'm using this
sum of squares
as the measure of error.
Again, some statisticians
would be -- they would say, OK,
I'll solve that problem
because it's the clean problem.
It leads to a beautiful
linear system.
But they would be a little
careful about these squares,
for -- in this case.
If one of these
points was way off.
Suppose I had a measurement at
t equal zero that was way off.
Well, would the straight line,
would the best line be the same
if I had this fourth point?
Suppose I have this
fourth data point.
No, certainly the line would --
it wouldn't be the -- that
wouldn't be the best line.
Because that line would
have a giant error --
and when I squared it it
would be like way out of sight
compared to the others.
So this would be called by
statisticians an outlier,
and they would not be happy to
see the whole problem turned
topsy-turvy by this one outlier,
which could be a mistake,
after all.
So they wouldn't -- so they
wouldn't like maybe squaring,
if there were outliers, they
would want to identify them.
OK.
I'm not going to --
I don't want to suggest that
least squares isn't used,
it's the most used, but
it's not exclusively used
because it's a little --
overcompensates for outliers.
Because of that squaring.
OK.
So suppose we don't
have this guy,
we just have these
three equations.
And I want to make --
minimize this error.
OK.
Now, what I said is there's
two pictures to look at.
One picture is this one.
The three points, the best line.
And the errors.
Now, on this picture,
what are these points
on the line, the points
that are really on the line?
So they're -- points, let
me call them P1, P2, and P3,
those are three numbers, so
this -- this height is P1,
this height is P2, this height
is P3, and what are those guys?
Suppose those were the
three values instead of --
there's b1, ev- everybody's
seen all these -- sorry,
my art is as usual
not the greatest,
but there's the given b1, the
given b2, and the given b3.
I promise not to put a single
letter more on that picture.
OK.
There's b1, P1 is the one on
the line, and e1 is the distance
between.
And same at points two
and same at points three.
OK, so what's up?
What's up with those Ps?
P1, P2, P3, what are they?
They're the components,
they lie on the line,
right?
They're the points
which if instead
of one, two, two, which
were the b's, suppose I put
P1, P2, P3 in here.
I'll figure out in a minute
what those numbers are.
But I just want to get the
picture of what I'm doing.
If I put P1, P2, P3 in
those three equations,
what would be good about
the three equations?
I could solve them.
A line goes through the Ps.
So the P1, P2, P3 vector,
that's in the column
space.
That is a combination
of these columns.
It's the closest combination.
It's this picture.
See, I've got the two
pictures like here's
the picture that
shows the points, this
is a picture in a
blackboard plane,
here's a picture that's
showing the vectors.
The vector b, which is in
this case, in this example
is the vector one, two, two.
The column space is in
this case spanned by the --
well, you see A there.
The column space of the matrix
one, one, one, one, two, three.
And this picture shows
the nearest point.
There's the -- that
point P1, P2, P3,
which I'm going to compute
before the end of this hour,
is the closest point
in the column space.
OK.
Let me -- t I don't dare
leave it any longer --
can I just compute it now.
So I want to compute --
find P. All right.
Find P. Find x, which
is CD, find P and P. OK.
And I really should put
these little hats on
to remind myself that they're
the estimated the best line,
not the perfect line.
OK.
How do I proceed?
Let's just run
through the mechanics.
What's the equation for x?
The -- or x hat.
The equation for that is A
transpose A x hat equals A
transpose x --
A transpose b.
The most --
I'm -- will venture to call
that the most important equation
in statistics.
And in estimation.
And whatever you're -- wherever
you've got error and noise this
is the estimate
that you use first.
OK.
Whenever you're fitting
things by a few parameters,
that's the equation to use.
OK, let's solve it.
What is A transpose A?
So I have to figure out
what these matrices are.
One, one, one, one, two, three
and one, one, one, one, two,
three, that gives me some
matrix, that gives me
a matrix, what do I get out of
that, three, six, six, and one
and four and nine, fourteen.
OK.
And what do I expect to see in
that matrix and I do see it,
just before I keep going
with the calculation?
I expect that matrix
to be symmetric.
I expect it to be invertible.
And near the end
of the course I'm
going to say I expect it
to be positive definite,
but that's a future fact
about this crucial matrix,
A transpose A.
OK.
And now let me
figure A transpose b.
So let me -- can I tack on b as
an extra column here, one, two,
two?
And tack on the extra
A transpose b is --
looks like five and one
and four and six, eleven.
I think my equations are three
C plus six D equals five,
and six D plus fourt-six C
plus fourteen D is eleven.
Can I just for safety
see if I did that right?
One, one, one times
one, two, two is five.
One, two, three, that's
one, four and six, eleven.
Looks good.
These are my equations.
That's my -- they're called
the normal equations.
I'll just write that
word down because it --
so I solve them.
I solve that for C and
D. I would like to --
before I solve them could I
do one thing that's on the --
that's just above here?
I would like to --
I'd like to find these
equations from calculus.
I'd like to find them from
this minimizing thing.
So what's the first error?
The first error is what I
missed by in the first equation.
C plus D minus one squared.
And the second error is what
I miss in the second equation.
C plus two D minus two squared.
And the third error squared is C
plus three D minus two squared.
That's my -- overall squared
error that I'm trying
to minimize.
OK.
So how would you minimize that?
OK, linear algebra has given us
the equations for the minimum.
But we could use calculus too.
That's a function of
two variables, C and D,
and we're looking
for the minimum.
So how do we find it?
Directly from calculus, we
take partial derivatives,
right, we've got two
variables, C and D,
so take the partial
derivative with respect to C
and set it to zero, and
you'll get that equation.
Take the partial
derivative with respect --
I'm not going to write it
all out, just -- you will.
The partial derivative with
respect to D, it -- you know,
it's going to be linear,
that's the beauty of these
squares,that if I have the
square of something and I take
its derivative I get something
And this is what I get. linear.
So this is the derivative of
the error with respect to C
being zero, and this
is the derivative
of the error with
respect to D being zero.
Wherever you look, these
equations keep coming.
So now I guess I'm
going to solve it,
what will I do, I'll subtract,
I'll do elimination of course,
because that's the only
thing I know how to do.
Two of these away from
this would give me --
let's see, six, so would
that be two Ds equals one?
Ha.
So it wasn't --
I was afraid these numbers
were going to come out awful.
But if I take two of
those away from that,
the equation I get left
is two D equals one,
so I think D is a
half and C is whatever
back substitution gives, six D
is three, so three C plus three
is five, I'm doing back
substitution now, right, three,
can I do it in light
letters, three C plus
that six D is three equals
five, so three C is two,
so I think C is two-thirds.
One-half and two-thirds.
So the best line, the best
line is the constant two-thirds
plus one-half t.
And I -- is my picture
more or less right?
Let me write, let me copy
that best line down again,
two-thirds and a half.
Let me -- I'll put in the
two-thirds and the half.
OK.
So what's this P1, that's
the value at t equal to one.
At t equal to one, I have
two-thirds plus a half,
which is --
what's that, four-sixths
and three-sixths, so P1, oh,
I promised not to write
another thing on this --
I'll erase P1 and
I'll put seven-sixths.
OK.
And yeah, it's above one,
and e1 is one-sixth, right.
You see it all.
Right?
What's P2?
OK.
At point t equal to two,
where's my line here?
At t equal to two, it's
two-thirds plus one, right?
That's five-thirds.
Two-thirds and t is two,
so that's two-thirds
and one make five-thirds.
And that's -- sure enough,
that's smaller than the exact
two.
And then final P3, when
t is three, oh, what's
two-thirds plus three-halves?
It's the same as
three-halves plus two-thirds.
It's -- so maybe
four-sixths and nine-sixths,
maybe thirteen-sixths.
OK, and again, look,
oh, look at this, OK.
You have to admire the
beauty of this answer.
What's this first error?
So here are the
errors. e1, e2 and e3.
OK, what was that
first error, e1?
Well, if we decide the
errors counting up,
then it's one-sixth.
And the last error,
thirteen-sixths
minus the correct two
is one-sixth again.
And what's this
error in the middle?
Let's see, the correct
answer was two, two.
And we got five-thirds and
it's the other direction,
minus one-third,
minus two-sixths.
That's our error vector.
In our picture, in our
other picture, here it is.
We just found P and e.
e is this vector, one-sixth,
minus two-sixths, one-sixth,
and P is this guy.
Well, maybe I have
the signs of e wrong,
I think I have, let me fix it.
Because I would like
this one-sixth --
I would like this plus the
P to give the original b.
I want P plus e to match b.
So I want minus a
sixth, plus seven-sixths
to give the correct b equal one.
OK.
Now -- I'm going to
take a deep breath here,
and ask what do we know
about this error vector e?
You've seen now this whole
problem worked completely
through, and I even think
the numbers are right.
So there's P, so let me --
I'll write -- if I can put
it down here, B is P plus e.
b I believe was one, two, two.
The nearest point
had seven-sixths,
what were the others?
Five-thirds and thirteen-sixths.
And the e vector was
minus a sixth, two-sixths,
one-third in other
words, and minus a sixth.
OK.
Tell me some stuff
about these two vectors.
Tell me something about
those two vectors,
well, they add to
b, right, great.
OK.
What else?
What else about those
two vectors, the P,
the projection vector P,
and the error vector e.
What else do you
know about them?
They're perpendicular, right.
Do we dare verify that?
Can you take the dot
product of those vectors?
I'm like getting like minus
seven over thirty-six,
can I change that to ten-sixths?
Oh, God, come out right here.
Minus seven over thirty-six,
plus twenty over thirty-six,
minus thirteen over thirty-six.
Thank you, God.
OK.
And what else should we
know about that vector?
Actually we know --
I've got to say we know
even a little more.
This vector, e, is
perpendicular to P,
but it's perpendicular
to other stuff too.
It's perpendicular not just to
this guy in the column space,
this is in the column
space for sure.
This is perpendicular
to the column space.
So like give me another
vector it's perpendicular to.
Another because it's
perpendicular to the whole
column space, not
just to this --
this particular
projection that's --
that is in the column space,
but it's perpendicular to other
stuff, whatever's
in the column space,
so tell me another vector
in the -- oh, well,
I've written down the matrix,
so tell me another vector
in the column space.
Pick a nice one.
One, one, one.
That's what
everybody's thinking.
OK, one, one, one is
in the column space.
And this guy is supposed
to be perpendicular to one,
one, one.
Is it?
Sure.
If I take the dot
product with one,
one, one I get minus a sixth,
plus two-sixths, minus a sixth,
zero.
And it's perpendicular
to one, two, three.
Because if I take the
dot product with one,
two, three I get minus one, plus
four, minus three, zero again.
OK, do you see the --
I hope you see the two pictures.
The picture here for vectors
and, the picture here
for the best line, and it's
the same picture, just --
this one's in the plane
and it's showing the line,
this one never did show the
line, this -- in this picture,
C and D never showed up.
In this picture, C and
D were -- you know,
they determined that line.
But the two are
exactly the same.
C and D is the combination
of the two columns
that gives P. OK.
So that's these squares.
And the special
but most important
example of fitting by
straight line, so the homework
that's coming then
Wednesday asks
you to fit by straight lines.
So you're just going to end
up solving the key equation.
You're going to end up
solving that key equation
and then P will be Ax hat.
That's it.
OK.
Now, can I put in a little
piece of linear algebra
that I mentioned
earlier, mentioned again,
but I never did write?
And I've -- I
should do it right.
It's about this matrix
A transpose A. There.
I was sure that that
matrix would be invertible.
And of course I wanted to
be sure it was invertible,
because I planned to solve this
system with with that matrix.
So and I announced
like before --
as the chapter
was just starting,
I announced that it
would be invertible.
But now I -- can I
come back to that?
OK.
So what I said was --
that if A has
independent columns,
then A transpose
A is invertible.
And I would like to --
first to repeat
that important fact,
that that's the requirement
that makes everything go here.
It's this independent
columns of A
that guarantees
everything goes through.
And think why.
Why does this matrix
A transpose A,
why is it invertible if the
columns of A are independent?
OK, there's -- so if it
wasn't invertible, I'm --
so I want to prove that.
If it isn't
invertible, then what?
I want to reach --
I want to follow that
-- follow that line --
of thinking and
see what I come to.
Suppose, so proof.
Suppose A transpose Ax is zero.
I'm trying to prove this.
This is now to prove.
I don't like hammer away at
too many proofs in this course.
But this is like
the central fact
and it brings in all
the stuff we know.
OK.
So I'll start the proof.
Suppose A transpose Ax is zero.
What -- and I'm aiming to prove
A transpose A is invertible.
So what do I want to prove now?
So I'm aiming to
prove this fact.
I'll use this, and I'm aiming
to prove that this matrix is
invertible, OK, so if I
suppose A transpose Ax is zero,
then what conclusion
do I want to reach?
I'd like to know
that x must be zero.
I want to show x must be zero.
To show now -- to prove x
must be the zero vector.
Is that right, that's what we
worked in the previous chapter
to understand, that a
matrix was invertible
when its null space is
only the zero vector.
So that's what I want to show.
How come if A transpose Ax is
zero, how come x must be zero?
What's going to be the reason?
Actually I have
two ways to do it.
Let me show you one way.
This is -- here, trick.
Take the dot product
of both sides with x.
So I'll multiply both
sides by x transpose.
x transpose A transpose
Ax equals zero.
I shouldn't have written trick.
That makes it sound
like just a dumb idea.
Brilliant idea, I
should have put.
OK.
I'll just put idea.
Now, I got to that equation,
x transpose A transpose Ax=0,
and I'm hoping you can
see the right way to --
to look at that equation.
What can I conclude
from that equation,
that if I have x
transpose A -- well,
what is x transpose
A transpose Ax?
Does that -- what
it's giving you?
It's again going to be putting
in parentheses, I'm looking
at Ax and what I seeing here?
Its transpose.
So I'm seeing here this
is Ax transpose Ax.
Equaling zero.
Now if Ax transpose Ax, so like
let's call it y or something,
if y transpose y is zero,
what does that tell me?
That the vector has
to be zero, right?
This is the length
squared, that's
the length of the vector Ax
squared, that's Ax times Ax.
So I conclude that
Ax has to be zero.
Well, I'm getting somewhere.
Now that I know Ax
is zero, now I'm
going to use my
little hypothesis.
Somewhere every mathematician
has to use the hypothesis.
Right?
Now, if A has independent
columns and we've --
we're at the point where Ax is
zero, what does that tell us?
I could -- I mean that could
be like a fill-in question
on the final exam.
If A has independent columns
and if Ax equals zero then what?
Please say it. x is zero, right.
Which was just what
we wanted to prove.
That -- do you see why that is?
If Ax eq- equals zero,
now we're using --
here we used this was
the square of something,
so I'll put in
little parentheses
the observation we made, that
was a square which is zero,
so the thing has to be zero.
Now we're using the hypothesis
of independent columns
at the A has
independent columns.
If A has independent
columns, this is telling me
x is in its null space,
and the only thing
in the null space of such a
matrix is the zero vector.
OK.
So that's the argument and
you see how it really used
our understanding of the
-- of the null space.
OK.
That's great.
All right.
So where are we then?
That board is like
the backup theory
that tells me that
this matrix had
to be invertible because these
columns were independent.
OK.
there's one case
of independent --
there's one case where the
geometry gets even better.
When the -- there's one case
when columns are sure to be
independent.
And let me put that -- let me
write that down and that'll be
the subject for next time.
Columns are sure -- are
certainly independent,
definitely independent,
if they're perpendicular.
Oh, I've got to rule
out the zero column,
let me give them all length one,
so they can't be zero if they
are perpendicular unit vectors.
Like the vectors one, zero,
zero, zero, one, zero and zero,
zero, one.
Those vectors are unit
vectors, they're perpendicular,
and they certainly
are independent.
And what's more, suppose
they're -- oh, that's so nice,
I mean what is A transpose
A for that matrix?
For the matrix with
these three columns?
It's the identity.
So here's the key to the
lecture that's coming.
If we're dealing with
perpendicular unit vectors
and the word for that will
be -- see I could have said
orthogonal, but I
said perpendicular --
and this unit vectors gets
put in as the word normal.
Orthonormal vectors.
Those are the best
columns you could ask for.
Matrices with -- whose
columns are orthonormal,
they're perpendicular
to each other,
and they're unit vectors, well,
they don't have to be those
three, let me do a
final example over here,
how about one at an angle like
that and one at ninety degrees,
that vector would be cos theta,
sine theta, a unit vector,
and this vector would be
minus sine theta cos theta.
That is our absolute favorite
pair of orthonormal vectors.
They're both unit vectors
and they're perpendicular.
That angle is ninety degrees.
So like our job next
time is first to see
why orthonormal
vectors are great,
and then to make vectors
orthonormal by picking
the right basis.
OK, see you.
Thanks.